hi everyone welcome to cloud next 2021
we're so excited you're here with us on
developer day so we're going to be
showing you how you can incorporate
google cloud's ai and ml offerings into
your app or service with our apis it
doesn't matter what platform or stack
you're using we've got you covered
today specifically we'll be talking
about google cloud document ai and how
to use it with our serverless offerings
such as cloud functions for business
logic and workflows for orchestrating
your services
but before we get started who are we
my name is anushari vastava and i'm a
developer advocate in new york focusing
on ai and ml bringing these services to
developers around the world
hello everyone i'm guillaume i'm also a
developer advocate at google uh but i'm
based in the paris office and i'm
focusing mainly on our serverless
technologies like cloud functions
cloudera and app engine and also our
orchestration solutions like workflows
awesome
so let's start with why we're here it's
google cloud's mission to help you
innovate faster towards your business
goals and there are several different
ways that we can help you do this
whether it's through storage solutions
infrastructure ai services scalable
computing data analytics and so much
more
enterprise are after smart easy and
scalable business solutions a lot of
these tools on gcp are there so you can
focus on your core business mission not
all these auxiliary functions so for
example if you have complex business
tasks the cloud helps you deploy develop
and scale you don't have to worry about
infrastructure management system updates
all of those things
maybe you have data in several different
sources that you need to use in a
streamlined fashion and then last but
not least machine learning by leveraging
our ai platform or our pre-trained
models you can incorporate machine
learning into your application without
having to get a phd in this field
we just want you to focus on the problem
that you're actually trying to solve and
nothing else
so these are the four trends that we're
actually seeing in this space
we're going to demo an expense report
application
backed by machine learning and running
on google cloud so now let's actually
dive into the specific products that
we'll be working with
so let's start with documents
so some of the most important data in
companies isn't actually living in
databases but rather in documents so
think about every time that you've had
to file an expense report
nearly all business processes either
begin include or end with a document
so this is where document ai comes in
this is a platform that we launched a ga
earlier this year in april and it helps
you turn your unstructured content into
structured data you know there's a lot
of important business information in
pdfs and images and these formats aren't
actually easily consumable to extract
data by a computer as it is so this is
what we actually call dark data so data
that companies have
um stored for either compliance reasons
or something else but you aren't
actually harnessing yet to
help decision making
help customers or
make better business decisions and this
is what document ai is there to help you
with
so there are lots of different ways that
you can use document ai
first we have generic document ai so we
actually have a toolkit of ocr we have
ocr trained for type forms as well as
handwritten forms this ocr is powerful
and then we even have something called
the form parser which will
understand any form that you feed it
it'll understand the question and answer
nature of that form and feed it back to
you key value pairs in a json format
that are much more easy to use than sort
of doing that parsing yourself from ocr
then in the middle we have specialized
document ai so we have trained several
models on the world's most common
business form types you can leverage
into your system this is going to be the
focus of our talk today but let me also
talk about custom document processing so
we also have tools in our toolkit that
you could train a model on your
proprietary business form types you can
ensure
accuracy
so specialized document ai we have
different solutions optimized for
different industry use cases so let me
talk about that
first we have lending document ai so
this is a set of specialized models for
forms such as w-2s w-9s bank statements
all of these are different pieces that
you have in a typical mortgage packet so
using the solution you can streamline
data capture and all of the different
steps that need to happen in a mortgage
process to make it faster
then in the middle we have procurement
document ai so this covers invoices
receipts utility statements and more and
this is what we'll be demoing today but
before we get there let me talk about
what we just launched at next this year
contracts document ai you know it's been
said that contracts can be some of the
most important business documents that
you have so we've trained models to
accept extract key pieces of information
that you can then use to make important
decisions like
programmatically understanding how long
the contract is valid things like that
so what's the magic in doc ai it's not
just ocr it's a whole pipeline
leveraging the technology that we've
been building at google for decades
so first we have doc prep so let's say
you upload an image of a wrinkled or
coffee stained document
we'll use image tools to
fix sku better enhance the text so it
can be data can be more easily extracted
then we get to split and classify we
want you to be able to leverage your
data and the raw form that it comes in
so think about a large pdf packet with
several different form types in it well
by using our splitting and classifying
tools you can actually identify
where these sub documents start and end
and what documents are there so then you
can take those specific pieces of your
packet and then feed them through the
correct processor
then we have entity extraction so this
is where we extract those key pieces of
information that you need per doctype so
even though you might have high varying
stock types every racine invoice might
look different we know that there are
pieces of information that are universal
to these document types so for
procurement you know every invoice is
going to have an invoice id every
receipt will have several line items
they'll have currency they'll have total
amounts they'll have tax values so we've
designed a schema per form type that you
can guarantee your data will be merged
into and returned into return to you in
your json response so this makes it much
easier when it's schematized to then
either feed into a database or give the
pieces of information that you need to a
downstream service
now
let's talk about the
some more magic pieces now we have
normalize and enrich
have you ever been coding with dates and
times and had a formatting mismatch you
know i'm in america in guillaume's and
france and we use different daytime
formats well document ai will do
normalization on monetary dates and
addresses so it's more easy to work with
whatever style your system is in
here we also use for enrichment the
google knowledge graph so the google
knowledge graph is a service that powers
search as well as several other
applications that lets you know
contextual relevant information so let's
say on your document you have an
incomplete business name or maybe an
address that isn't full or correct the
google knowledge graph will supplement
this information with the key pieces of
information that you could then find you
know in a search query
then last but not least we know with
these critical business processes you
have no room for error
so with the human the loop platform you
can select a confidence threshold where
you can have a document reviewed if
certain keys don't meet a certain value
say 95 98 confidence or if the whole
document doesn't meet that confidence
threshold
so i know we went through that really
fast but
now let's work on taking this api and
turning it into a full-fledged
application so i'm going to hand it over
to guillaume to tell us how we're going
to do that
thank you anu uh i know described the
big piece of the puzzle which is where
most of the smarts are but we'll need
some business logic some business
processes to integrate everything
together to create a full-blown useful
application for our end users
in a short moment i'll show you how we
use document ai cloud functions and
workflows to craft a smart expense
report solution but how are we going to
do it
well we are going to use uh google cloud
serverless solutions for business logic
thanks to cloud function
what is solace and why should we use
that instead of your homegrown servers
or virtual machines sublight solutions
allow you to focus on your application
and not on infrastructure management or
provisioning serverless products like
cloud functions are fully managed
environments developers can use to
easily deploy and scale their logic with
that hassle so from a programming model
perspective we usually create stateless
services based architectures which scale
more simply and last but not least since
the scaling is handled by the platform
for you we also apply a pay only for
usage pricing model where you pay really
proportional to the actual usage of your
application
cloud functions is a bit like some cloud
glue for a more programmable cloud tying
various useful services together
reacting through events flying through
your system there are long way to run
times available or all major programming
languages whether it's node.js python
and java and more
cloud functions react to events like
incoming http requests background events
from the cloud like a new file stored on
cloud storage or a new document in cloud
firestore or
nosql database and you can easily deploy
small units of business logic on the
platform from the console the google
cloud console or from the command line
as well
applications
are often composed of several services
or apis that you can call intern to
create the overall business process like
invoking the document ai api
or calling firestore to store some
structured data
as well as some cloud functions to
implement some logic like finding the
right information from the document ai's
output
for orchestrating those apis and
services we can take advantage of cloud
google cloud workflows
workflows is a solution to orchestrate
google cloud and http based api services
including third-party it doesn't have to
be
something solely you know hosted on
google cloud
and to tie them into subless workflows
it's about automating complex processes
workflow is a fully managed service
requiring no infrastructure or capacity
planning
it offers fast scalability support
scaling down to zero when not used and a
pay-per-use pricing model per step in
the in the workflow per step model and
last but not least for the developer
experience it deploys instantaneously
you have a yaml based declarative
language you can also use json actually
with variables with expressions and
formulas
you can apply some conditional logic for
conditional step execution and branching
into your workflow steps
with uh what else built in json parsing
when you need to parse the api output
the from the api that you call with
error and retry logic
when an api fails and you need to retry
and call it again and various other
useful built-in functions
there's also built-in authentication for
google cloud apis and
services so for example
uh services that would be hosted on
cloudread or cloud functions are pretty
much transparently authenticated when
called from the workflow definition
it executes workflows with the
reliability required for enterprise and
line of business applications workflows
offers fast scheduling of workflow
executions and transition between the
various tasks and steps and also
predictable performance with no cold
start at all in terms of pricing as i
said it's a per step execution pricing
approach
so let's have a look at a demonstration
it's an expense report application we'll
use document ai for the smart parsing of
the receipts cloud functions for some
logic for invoking the workflow calling
callback endpoints for the manager pro
or also transforming some light etl for
transforming some complex data into
simpler data structure that will store
uh in cloud file store as structured
data and of course workflows to
orchestrate the whole process so let's
have a look at the demonstration here is
our expense report application as an
employee
i have access to this page where i can
select and upload some receipts
to create my expense report so let's
click on the select button
i'm going to pick a couple
receipts
then i'm going to click the submit
report button
so the receipts are being uploaded and
the report is submitted and now it's
already in the processing queue it's
going to be handled by document ai who's
going to look at the
items the line items the supplier etc
that are recognized in those receipts
now let's have a look at the
administration page which is the page
that managers uh will be able to look at
to
accept reject approve
expense reports so here we already have
one report waiting in the queue
so the previous report that was
submitted contained two receipts i can
click to see the the details
so there's the braintree restaurant the
referral restaurant and i can see some
details of what was ordered the price
the total amount the currency
and document ai is able to do some data
enrichment so i could potentially see
the knowledge graph information
for example with the details about the
address of the restaurant
then
if i'm happy with this
expense report i can just click on
approve or if i'm unhappy i can click on
reject
and all those actions are actually going
through the
workflow
the workflow definition and for example
now i can see that my report came into
the approved section that's the one that
i just approved
and uh yeah the the one i had submitted
just a few seconds
ago arrived this time the the vendor
wasn't recognized but at least the
amount the currency and the details were
um
handled nicely
so let's have a look at how
it's done under the hood so first of all
i'm going to show you the uh workflow
definition
so as i said everything is going to
the workflow through the workflow so
whenever there's an action in the ui
it's going through some cloud function
uh invoking the the workflow
so for example here i'm preparing my
workflow definition with with some
variables but let's have a look at this
one
with workflows you can call rest apis
any api whether it's from google your
own apis or it could be third-party
external apis but here i'm not calling
document ai directly i'm actually
calling a connector which is a dedicated
wrapper run the rest api for document ai
and what's great with that is that
although
invoking
the batch process of going through all
the receipts i don't have to handle the
the waiting logic queueing etc
i just need to say okay i'm submitting
all those uh receipts they are here
uh you'll find everything uh there and
i'm interested in the results uh please
put the results of the
processed annotations uh
in in cloud storage
so in a few lines we're able to call
document ai and then so either it's
working or there there's an error
potentially so we might branch in
different places of our workflow and by
the way you can see the visualization of
your workflow on the right side here
i'm updating firestore to explain what
the status is
but here if the the parsing succeeded we
can have a look at
the
the annotations
the the results uh returned by document
ai and we have a little cloud function
here that's going to parse the json file
generated by document ai to find the
relevant details i'm interested in
so this is
this function process annotations
and
what it's doing here is that
i'm going to tell this cloud function
okay let's have a look at the files in
this storage bucket where the json
generated by document ai
is located then i'm going to go through
all the files each file each receipt has
a file associated with it
so i'm downloading the file locally and
i'm passing it with json and then i'm
going to hunt for the interesting fields
for example i'm curious about the
supplier name
i want to learn about all the line items
that are available each line okay i
order the pizza i order some some drink
i'm also interested in the total amount
of money but also the currency because
it's important to know which currency
was used and then i'm creating this
summary and then
i'm storing that in firestore all the
metadata i'm storing that in in
firestore
and
let's go to
file store where i can see the results
here
so what's stored in firestore that's
uh things like the status whether here
it's awaiting validation
but here i see the line items for this
first receipt the line terms for the
order receipt
but if you come back here you'll notice
that the report is awaiting validation
because we want
the manager to approve or reject this
report so that's
why we have the approve and reject
button but what's happening here we've
got the workflow that is running
but there's a very useful feature in
workflow that's called callbacks
a callback is a way to
wait for some external input whether
it's a human input here it's the the
manager that's going to approve this
report but it could be some external
system that is going to call back the
workflow to continue its execution
and let me show you
uh this part of the workflow i'm
creating a callback here
so i'm saying i'm ready to received uh
a post
an http post on the url that workflow is
going to generate for me
and then i'm also going to wait for the
workflow to be the callback to be called
so this is here a weight called back
and i'm waiting just an hour but i could
wait uh longer potentially up to one
year
and then either it works or not it's
rejected or perhaps there's an error and
i update firestore with this uh
information and that's where
here again uh i interact with firestore
to store
the approval or
rejection
so that's about it for the demo
so to recap what you saw in this demo
here's an architecture diagram that sums
it up so we have
the the two web pages for uh the
employee submitting the expense report
and for the manager approving the report
so the first step is to upload uh the
receipts into cloud storage buckets
we'll do that thanks to
firebase storage which uploads the
document into cloud storage buckets
then again from the ui from the employee
view
we'll go through a cloud function that
is going to
invoke workflows to create an execution
and start the execution of our workflow
what workflow is going to do well it's
going to uh well store some data about
the
the
the expense report that's been submitted
but then it's going to invoke document
ai
and let document ai fetch the receipts
from cloud storage analyze the receipts
and then store the result into a json
file in another
bucket a cloud storage bucket
then the workflow is going to call
another function
whose job is going to actually go
through the chasm data and pick up just
the right information we're interested
in
line items supplier name amount little
amount currency etc
so we've got the data
in the manager view the manager will be
able to click on either
buttons the one approving the expense
report or the one rejecting the expense
report and we'll go through the callback
the callback url from this web page
we'll call back into the workflow
through a cloud function to continue the
execution of the workflow and store the
result uh approved or rejected in our
cloud file store database and that's
about it for this architecture diagram
of our expense report application
so thanks a lot for your attention we'd
like to encourage you to have a look at
those few links here to get started on
document ai workflows and cloud
functions we are really looking forward
to hearing from you
about what you're going to you're going
to build next with those technologies
yeah so you can take a look at the
source code of what we showed today um
guillaume and i had a lot of fun
building this we used node.js with all
of these services uh we've published the
code to github let us know what you
think tweet us what you're going to
build or what you're excited for and let
us know how we can help